hey
good to see you it's been a while
24 hours for people to judge that's a
work week
now we're going to talk about the war
but first it's friday so we should do
something really stupid something really
idiotic because god knows we need it
like two heaping scoops of dumb
it's the cuomo's
[Music]
starring andrew
and chris
[Music]
yeah they're back like that rash i got
from cat's couch
the disgraced governor and live action
count chocula is suggesting he might run
again for new york governor good luck
getting the elderly vote since he offed
so many of them true he may be the only
democrat that'll have a hard time
getting dead people to vote for him i
have a lot of options i'm open to all of
them
i'm hoping for an offer from the new
york jets i still think i could play
wide receiver
have you seen the jess plan
uh so i'm open to all options and i'm
gonna leave it at that
well the guy knows his baseball i'll
give him that
now his disgraced brother chris is up in
the lawsuit demand against cnn to 125
million bucks
now cuomo is calling out his former
co-workers and that leads me to a
confused place it reminds me of puberty
which means it's time for
[Music]
greg's internal
dilemma there's a fight between people
you dislike who do you root for
well let's start with the idiot brother
i should be more specific
let's go with chris
he's not only suing cnn but bashing his
former co-workers including jeff zucker
brian stelter and the airbrushed block
of stupid known as don lemon wednesday
in his court filing he trashed his
brotherly buffoon
even mentioning how lemon warned jesse
smilet that the cops didn't buy his fake
hate crime adding that quote lemon was
not disciplined in any way unquote cat
well he was
he was disciplined
but a spanking hardly qualifies as
punishment when you pay for it
but it's weird to see lemon get trashed
by someone who cared for him so
so so deeply i'll talk to you soon mr
christopher cuomo i love you brother i
love you don if you watch a certain
state tv and you listen to conservative
media you would think that you know
entire cities are just you know enrolled
in fights and fires and whatever we went
out had a great dinner right makes me
love you more dee lemon i love you
brother i love you i love you d lemon
you and your whack tie i love you too
brother oh you love them you love them
the way i love you dilemma i love you
brother i'll see you soon all right have
a great weekend you're a partner here
and i'm just happy to have you back
because nobody bounces off each other
between shows like you and i do now go
on
i love you dealer i love you brother
yeah nobody nobody bounces like that
it's like romeo and juliet for cologne
drenched knuckleheads and here i thought
that was as real as the moon landing and
by moon landing i'm referring to brian
stelter sitting on a toilet
that's true
so
look we haven't been doing fun news in a
while so give me a break so it turns out
it was as fake yeah as fake as cat's
love for jazz
but the love affair now has gone sour i
haven't been blindsided by a breakup
like this since donnie left marie
they were brother and sister so it's
okay so yeah it's surprising that two
men who profess their love for each
other over and over again would now rip
each other to shreds you know i'm
starting to think that almost everything
on that network is a lie
now i don't blame cuomo after his firing
lemon said chris shouldn't get severance
since he broke journalistic standards
which is funny having lemon lecturing
someone on journalistic standards that's
like taking voice lessons from neil
young or learning how to meditate from
judge jeanine
bottom line they're all phonies
including chris so who do you root for
it's like a fight between dracula and
frankenstein i'm referring to pelosi and
biden
but this rift tells a bigger story it's
a lesson about the media and that
nothing they do is true even their
friendships they make it all up and they
think you're dumb enough to buy it like
the 1619 project or russian collusion or
hunter's laptop being disinformation or
that kill me doesn't live out of his car
we know he does most of the media is
just a collection of thirsty shallow
hacks bent on fame and fortune and when
it goes sour they'll sue their best pal
and that goes for america's sweetheart
too dana perrino she just as soon cut
you as look at you
hi kid i think
actually we do all get along here at fox
news here's me in hammer's hot tub
here's me in stuart varney's hot tub
and here's me under dana purino's bed
that was a surprise
so i don't care who wins this lawsuit i
just want you to know that they lie
about everything from big things like
collusion and crime to the little things
like mere friendship
okay now to his bro andrew he's a
jackass true and a creep that's true but
he's still more competent than the
current governor we have here kathy
what's her name who by the way wasn't
voted in by the people
she's such a dim bulb she couldn't light
up a glove compartment she wouldn't
budge on ridding the bail reforms even
as people died between her and andrew
cuomo they're responsible for the death
of more new yorkers than loose subway
greats and falling air conditioners
combined but now she's coming around
with an election looming too late i say
so that's the dilemma the lesser two
evils if only there was a solution and
maybe there is
shall i read you a tweet i saw from last
night here goes
hey greg do you have any pictures of
cat's feet
oh sorry that's a wrong one frickin
geraldo
this is from our very own janice dean
quote if andrew cuomo tries to run for
governor again maybe the weather [ __ ]
will too
well that would be awesome because if
she runs she wins because unlike the
others she's real and she's likable and
there's nothing in her background or
past that would sink her she's so clean
you could eat off her forehead
trust me i have
she's so spotless she makes dana purino
look like pig pen
and mark my words if she does run i will
help her
meaning i won't endorse her
let's welcome tonight's guests
she has the heart of a libertarian and
the glasses of a librarian host of
kennedy and fox business kennedy
kardashian lowe pattinson just to name a
few hollywood robs more famous than this
one tv writer and producer rob long
she gets up so early birds tell her to
keep the worm fox and friends first
co-host carly shimkus
and she's so white hunter biden tried to
snort her fox news contributor
cat tim
i don't know if that was necessary but
it i had to use it whatever no it's not
uh happy st patrick's day thank you yeah
today can't wait to go out and have some
guinness yo have you checked your have
you checked your calendar are you
working for off 2022
yeah just checking because you know you
might be off by a day no
okay all right well you know it's going
to be fun go to the parade yeah
that's my plan after yeah yeah parades
are at 1 30 a.m yes that's true that's
true just go out there alone oh yeah go
out there alone
kennedy hi
how are you very well thank you do you
are you do you miss the chris dawn love
fest as much as i do that montage i i
could never imagine being so satisfied
as i was by that uh because if you are
willing to name someone that you love so
much you profess your love nightly you
know it's like you you have written she
experienced sonnets to this person right
with your jackass tongue and limited
intellect
he did that and and then he names him in
a lawsuit which
that's the thing that makes him
unemployable this is the thing like
prospective employers look at this and
they don't go oh it wasn't him helping
his brother like we get that you know it
wasn't these allegations from other
women those are awful but you know it's
like half the guys in our newsroom have
done worse it's the fact that he went
after everyone that he used to work with
by name and trash them who would ever
want to employ something like that
exactly once you start suing you know
people you claim to love everybody
everybody's on the table rob if you
catch my drift i just winked at you i
saw that very uncomfortable i try to
make it here i'm trying to make you feel
as awkward point on the doll where i
feel the most vulnerable
and you know i have that oh i know you
do in my office we'll go together
so isn't this emblematic or symbolic of
what the media is it's manufactured
theater right it's pretty it's like even
the even the friendships are fake well i
mean okay yeah i mean i think
one thing you're missing here is it's
about
100 million dollars yes so the price on
their friendship is less than 100
million dollars right which i kind of
buy although i'd like to see it here i'd
like to see like you know
you know laura ingram and tucker carlson
i love you lolo i love you t carl i love
you carl
right i mean just try it just for a week
see how it goes that is an amazing idea
i wonder if anybody would catch on i
love you g j watt i love you hey i love
you gg
you're my bro i'm kind of great and i i
know and i mean no disrespect but if one
of those people is fired for whatever
reason right and they sue for 100
million dollars
they will trash the place yeah that is
what you do for 100 million yeah and
then you never work again because you
don't have to because you got you have
100 million dollars
which today is about 10 million
i don't get out of bed for 100 million
well when it comes to the cuomo's it's i
mean their ego is so big it's like a
movie there's just going to be a
downfall right and it's like they
haven't even been humbled
like you said chris cuomo isn't worth
125 million dollars is he crazy and then
let's not forget when andrew cuomo was
making his resignation speech
his rebuttal to sexually harassing 11
women was that he was italian right and
then he and he made that preposterous
explanation with a straight face like
everybody would believe him uh so no the
one isn't he get gonna get or shouldn't
get the 125 million and the other's not
going to be governor again yeah
you know uh and that means an opening
for janice dean which i i do believe
that she would win but kat i want to ask
you a question because uh it's
i when i was writing here
what is i mean how do you know if you're
not how do you know if you're not fake
like i what if i i mean i could be fake
fake my point is fake people don't know
they're fake like they just did they did
all of that for years
and they're fake but they didn't know
that like do you ever wonder if you're
fake or real no because for me it's the
lack of impulse control that prevents me
from being fake yes i think i'd have to
do more thinking in order to uh develop
that but i get you don't know until it's
too late yeah right you don't know he
thought it was a cool thing but again
125 million dollars that is also an
insane
number like for future earnings yes he
has a lot of confidence you know in his
career
for being the guy with a show nobody
watched yeah exactly that's the weird
thing they get terrible ratings what if
you did that with shannon brembo what if
you toss her and you're like i love you
shannon bream she was like i am so
uncomfortable
exactly she's like please start calling
me evil again yes yes yes i'll just do
it to mike emanuel should uh last
question should janice run yes yes
because okay i would vote for her at a
heartbeat yeah yeah cuomo called her a
[ __ ] which like okay men get called
[ __ ] if they're weak but women get
called [ __ ] for being assertive so
that already means she's a leader plus
she doesn't strike me as much of a
groper no that's true that's true
although politics is awful she's too
good for that however
with her weather background she'll
always know when to call in the snowplow
that's absolutely right and she's she's
not going to close schools because now
they're all zooming yeah she would be
fantastic kathy hokul sucks she got
she's the the current newer governor
that no one knows she got booed at a
rangers game the other night when she
dropped the ceremonial puck oh she's not
good either what a pucking idiot
i'm a single issue voter yes if i can go
and get a drink and then walk out of the
restaurant with a drink and walk down
the street with it you have my vote
there you go that's so true that's so i
am definitely a governor kathy uh
partisan at right now exactly i'm
willing to listen to other offers from
other other uh uh i'll talk to janice
i'm gonna be here like invisible
i won't i won't do that i'm too lazy and
i really don't care
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else